from that pda moment between addison
ray's mom and young gravy
to allegations of infidelity against her
father
the tick tock stars got a lot of family
drama
women we're all human
and now the source is filling e.t in on
how addison feels yeah i don't know it's
so hard i'm like speechless 99 of the
time our source says addison's
embarrassed by her parents sherry
easterling and monty lopez and keeping
her distance
why well it all began in july when
infidelity allegations against her dad
surfaced
sheri spoke out about the claims on
instagram she even changed her bio to
single mom if anyone knows me
for who i am and like growing up it was
her and get this that same month young
gravy enters the mix
[Music]
and the 26 year old rapper well he's got
eyes for 42 year old sherry
oh it's on sight baby
by august mati caught wind of the whole
thing and challenged gravy to a fight
someone who knows how to have a little
fun
dvd on any boxing matches but one thing
we do know gravy and sherry are heating
up what is the obsession with no they're
more experienced they are uh an under
service community i'd like to say yeah
the pair wasn't shy about flaunting
their pda at the vmas gravy took sherry
as his date but is it about young gravy
he's very wholesome i would say
believe it or not i am a wholesome
person i am wholesome you know what i
felt like the response that you gave to
addison's father on tick tock after he
challenged you to a fight was pretty
mature i thought it was in a prayer
period i feel like i am a lot more you
know i feel like as a 26 year old i'm a
lot more mature than you know
that type of activity so what did you
make of the tick tock activity
um i don't i don't let's not worry about
it
and addison she's also not worried our
source says she's staying focused on
work and doesn't want any family feud to
impact her future quote addison doesn't
want to acknowledge what's going on
publicly and is trying to stay in her
own lane she isn't paying attention to
their relationships or social posting
addison made her mark in 2021 dropping
her first single obsessed and movie he's
all that there's more to you than what
you let everyone see
and when it spoke about her film debut
she teased lots of unexpected projects
to come
where do you want to go from here is it
more movies do you have more music
coming out uh definitely want to keep on
going with the movies i'm very excited
for that lots of new exciting things
coming up but not too much that i can
talk about yet
but it's all going to be really exciting
and hopefully kind of going to surprise
a lot of people
[Music]
you